[Music]
covert 19 has brought the global economy
to its knees
the pandemic has been an enormous
synchronized global economic shock on a
scale which has not been seen since the
second world war
by the end of 2020 the world's gdp may
be about
seven and a half percent lower than it
would have been without the pandemic
globally more than 15 percent of young
people
who were in work before covert 19 have
lost their jobs
widespread lockdowns have turbocharged
changes
that were already affecting the world
economy in technology
finance and trade how governments adapt
to these seismic changes
will determine how rapidly countries
economies can recover
[Music]
in april this year american unemployment
was the highest since the depression
back then around a quarter of americans
were jobless
but from the bleak depression of the
1930s was born the new deal an ambitious
federal plan to create jobs and
kickstart the economy
40 of those speaking works have funded
we have a long way to go but we are on
the way
the crises of the 20th century forced
governments to change their policies
for the better it's often been the case
that after
big periods of economic upheaval you've
had a reforging of the relationship
between the individual and the state
the second world war was followed by an
expansion of the welfare state in europe
and high unemployment and inflation of
the 1970s
led to ronald reagan's and margaret
thatcher's free market economics
but in the 21st century the largest
economic shocks
have not led to such a change
the global financial crisis people
thought maybe you'd have a rethinking of
how banking worked but in the end
you only got incremental reform the
effects of
trade with china were not adequately
anticipated by western policymakers
they did not think about the impact it
would have on some workers who were
exposed
to it and i don't think that enough
thinking had been done
about the implications of of big tech
for the economy and society
[Music]
those on the losing side of these
economic shifts
have felt left behind the result is
you've got the rise of populist
politicians like president trump
to vote for brexit the rise of of of
right-wing
economically nationalist populism around
the world
and then among the young you have this
leftward drift
this support for politicians like bernie
sanders for checkmate corbyn
the pandemic is the fourth economic
shock of the 21st century
this time governments could choose to
respond differently
in the aftermath of the global financial
crisis
many governments especially in europe
chose to tighten their belts
rather than spend the result was slow
economic recovery
you had governments which turned to
fiscal austerity
to cutting spending to balance their
budgets too
soon which also weakened the recovery
uh and made it slower than it otherwise
could have been now we have the pandemic
an economic downturn that's very deep
and i think it's important that
governments
don't repeat the mistakes of the 2010s
so far
spending is exactly what governments
have been doing and to pay for that
spending
governments have been borrowing a lot
to keep borrowing costs down central
banks in america
britain japan and the euro area have
created new money
worth almost four trillion dollars
that money has financed household income
payments
furloughed millions of workers and
bailed out businesses
[Music]
at the moment interest rates are very
low and so despite the fact that you
have this enormous debt that's been run
up as a result of the pandemic
the costs of servicing it are not high
so there is no doubt that there's space
for governments to support the economy
but no one knows if or when interest
rates are going to rise
and should that happen it'll be the
taxpayer force to shoulder the burden
of this vast public debt
the balanced governments have to strike
is not turning to austerity too quickly
but then once if and when interest rates
start to rise
to be aware that they are very indebted
and they need to ensure that their
fiscal policies are sustainable
[Music]
the pandemic has brought about enormous
changes
perhaps the biggest is that for many
people the office has gone from here
to here and on the whole
they seem to prefer it sixty percent of
americans who can work from home
want to continue doing it at least one
day a week after covert
and in the long term it could boost
economic growth
and actually decrease inequality one of
the
chief constraints on growth was the fact
that it was very expensive
to live near cities where jobs were
increasingly congregating especially
good jobs
places like london paris san francisco
new york tokyo
so there is clearly an opportunity if
people do shift towards working from
home
to ease that constraint working remotely
has been made possible thanks to a fast
and widespread adoption of technology
which existed before the pandemic but
wasn't being used to its full potential
this digital push that's now taking
place as a result of the pandemic
will lead to accelerated change in the
economy
ultimately disruption is what drives
long-term living standards
the important thing is that governments
i think embrace this change
rather than standing in the way and
seeing it as a scary force
that must be stopped of course not
everyone will benefit
from the remote work revolution the
urban service sector in particular is
expected to shrink
but voters may be more likely to support
disruption
if the risks are shared more equally
[Music]
when the world went into lockdown
millions of businesses found themselves
unable to operate
and with no way to pay their employees
so governments were forced to respond
in an innovative way i think that's
because there was this widespread sense
that you couldn't do anything about the
fact that you were uh
unemployed as a result of your the
restaurant at which you worked being
shut
lockdowns were bolt from the blue and so
the government stood behind everybody
and replaced household incomes to an
extraordinary degree
in america congress announced a stimulus
package worth two trillion dollars
which included direct cash payments to
almost every american
the british government rolled out a 30
billion pound job support scheme
and in europe's five largest economies
more than 40 million workers were placed
on government-funded
short work schemes
the downside to furlough schemes is that
they
do have this potential to keep people
locked in zombie jobs which aren't
coming back
when the economy recovers but the
principle
the household incomes in some sense can
be underwritten
during a large economic shock over which
those households have no control
is i think an interesting one that uh
that could be applied
in future what we've seen this year is
the governments can move
pretty fast to put money in the pockets
of households directly
and the households will spend that money
direct cash transfers to households
uh do work fairly well and are not
subject to quite the same level of
of haggling and perhaps the same degree
of waste you might get with other forms
of fiscal stimulus
while governments have sought to
intervene domestically
internationally there's also been an
increase in protectionism
when countries shield their industries
against foreign competition
the crisis has caused panic about the
fragility of global supply chains
stalled production lines across china
the global supply chain right now
is disrupted a lot of firms this year
pay a lot more attention to their supply
chains
and it's more fashionable now to think
about the robustness and resilience of
those supply chains
which often means bringing them closer
to the home or at least diversifying
your suppliers there was concern in
particular
around personal protective equipment
many countries blocked
export of ppe and similar items
according to the imf there have been
almost 120
new export restrictions this year this
is uh
coinciding with a movement towards
protectionism
on a global scale with a trade war
between america and china
and it's clearly a risk that coming out
of the pandemic you have leaders
who are very concerned about promoting
national champions
less concerned about competition rules
and really want supply chains brought
home
despite this shift towards protectionism
there
is reason to be optimistic government
economic response to the virus
has been swift and on a massive scale
i don't think many people would have
predicted that government
would act that fast and that capably
they've acted much better i would say on
the economic side
than they have in terms of controlling
the disease in many countries
as with the economic shocks of the 20th
century
covert 19 presents an opportunity
for a reforging of the relationship
between government and the individual
in ways that many hoped would follow the
previous shocks of the 21st century
the question is whether today's politics
is up to the job
hi i'm henry kerr the economist
economics editor
i've written a special report on the
effect the pandemic is having on the
world economy
you can read it by clicking the link
opposite thanks for watching
[Music]